Wanted to talk about something. I can't remember what it is now. Um,
bro.
When I was in, when I was in.
My early twenties, I would go to this place. Bob's big boy. They got,
they had really good burgers and I almost,
I probably ate one every night for the hole for a year.
When I wasn't really concerned about my health. I was like 22.
Still looked like a, you know, they would, people would be like,
what's going on? Is that one of the, is it a velociraptor?
Just because of how my body looked, not a good thing. Um,
so, and uh, and I would,
and I would eat burgers just all the time and I would go to Bob's big boy and I
would go and there was this guy named. What was his name? Ooh, Thai.
UT AI. That was his name. Where was he from? Mars.
Where's that name from? You got me baby.
Never heard the name before in my life had hair, like a Lego guy,
like had hair, like it was a spar.
Tin hat.
His hair had more hairs capita than Neil deGrasse, Tyson.
Billions and billions of particles. Billions of follicles in my hair,
in my head started billions and billions of years ago.
Yeah. And he had an OU tie. Where's it from?
Looked like he could be from, for.
Real Mexico, Hawaii.
Or Japan. Where was he from? Bow tie. Um,
and so I really like to go Bob's
big boy, man. I started to know everybody there.
There was a waitress named Denise. There was a guy named Kevin.
Kevin always looked like an eighties action movie star. I liked Kevin a lot.
He'd be like, Hey, what's going on man? And we'd just chat and. He'd be like,
you want the burger? And I'm like, of course I'm here. Aren't I,
but every time I got Ooh, Thai, you would come up.
And never said anything.
I swear to God,
but this is skip.
That's what he would say. He'd come up. He'd say it's good. And I'd say,
okay, um, yeah, I'll get the burger and he'd write it down. And I'd say thanks.
And he'd say let's skip is skip dude.
E S C I B. And anytime I would bring it up new person there I'd be like,
ah, OOD eyes here. Watch he's going to say a skip. And they'd be like, what,
what the is a skip? I say, you just sit back and relax. He would come up, skip.
What do you want? I'll I'll get the salad skip.
And one time,
one night I realized what he was saying.
And I remember thinking, oh, that's what he's saying.
And a week later I forgot what I realized it was.
And I have never been able to remember it again.
And I'm so that I don't remember. What I figured out is skip was
I think about it every now and then you never know when some like that's going
to hit in life, man, write this down is scared,
but what the is the scare booed? I
skip.
What could it mean is skip.
It's not, uh, it w maybe it was trying to say something it's good,
but it wasn't, it wasn't, it, it wasn't that it's good. It was a skip dude.
I'd watch his mouth.
I'd watch his mouth do the escape. And the book at the end
never gave a about me at all. Denise was a
sweet. Um, and, uh,
and then I went back years later and the, I was like, Hey, how's Kevin been?
And he, I think he died. I was like, what?
A gay died. Sad, man. He was just like a young guy.
I wonder if Buddha is still there. Let me look up food.
I Bob's big boy Burbank.
Bob's big boy,
boy. What if he just had like 50,000 followers on Instagram?
It was a skip on his,
his Instagram handle is escape. And he's just like living that a of life.
And he's just like this.
I still don't know where he is. Cause he's in different places.
Just he's just other guys in Wales bathrooms. And it's just like, oh no,
you just went on a family. Oh no escape. He goes into the thing. Oh no.
Whoops. Oh no. Just
blasted hair. All wet, but still puffy. Cause he's got so much.
Hiro wit, but still puffy Cousy cast. So much.
Morale. JZ did the yeah.
Travis, Scott shouldn't play in a super bowl because they don't stand with cap.
What the NFL wants me to.
Be oversee what they're doing with football.
I sign it as long as I can make money.
That's what people think he's doing.
I don't know if that's what he's doing or not. Um,
but people are up in arms is Bob's big boy.
I looked up OOD. I,
I images for OOD. I Bob's big boy. You know,
let's go to images. Nope.
I can't believe I remember his name, but not if Kevin actually died,
what the is wrong with my brain that I remember some guy saying his skin and
his name was OOD. I.
But I can't actually remember if the guy I liked the most there died.
What the dude.
Dude, there was a TMZ thing that somebody tweeted me and was like.
They were like, oh, well.
This is funny or something. And I watched it.
Bro. I have zero.
Recollection of it. I'm.
39. I mean, I'm not even.
Close to 40 dude.
I have zero idea about a TMZ guy coming.
Up to me, asking me about some.
And then a homeless guy came up to me and did it, did a joke. I don't remember.
It could be a deep fake for all. I know.
[Inaudible].
All right. I don't want to upgrade the thing, dude, Mack, you know.